[Applause]
good morning live on tour in cai historic
moment
marwa edifico challenge the challenge is
shaken by the crisis the crisis environment
and crisis all of us to face
continues to move shawn levy heart
disease week end of economic
inequalities of economic north b limited
to production and  distribution il must
bear consider it simple di environment
and of people we could say the economist
di
create da giorni in together update
transformation shift change
marco moutinot as crysis images news
the show meet wind generation without
compromising possibility to many prophets
north end of people of goo  two days
not a fashion group family school of
business institutions chemical
substances contribution five years ago
i've got di
Sì dedicated to rechero in Circa
concept of ecology Integral colo gnv
the show at one integra vision onlive
via interdependence need to find
economic technology of finance  and
educational of the courses in worked
change and right  orientation forever
days of integral ecology require
first take on educational step then
prince michael jackson e rape monza a
tellaro education gearto world car of
developing di understanding the
environment problems hurley
e vero la miss in education based
sanctified and unknown ethical approaches
is important many people ready shoah new
ecological in social
bern the best the fight jenner rose
lee ford defenders environment for
justice compro poso vi must focus on
water and nutrition access to safe and
drink ball water is one sense and
universal human rights and it is sense
doctor isaac conditions of other
rights and responsibilities nutrition su
non distrarti farmi mètres sud con the
main orders in tailleur cycle of food
production and distribution
the third proposed third gesture is about
energy transition radio replacements but
san babila or her I made the film
sweet  chin a few years
the scientists calculated up santis estimated
prox in there  of me a few years inside
of plastic iridium greenhouse gas
emissions fake atmosphere
this transition must be not only
mass destruction b here also people off
meeting present and future margins
that must rather must be tried to
impact on local compilations his
lance  ondoso working di energy
productions actors estoul il business
network di argentini to commit dancehaus
integral che han of our common excluding
from investment companies that do not
made parameters of integrale colo g wire
the world of that work concret this
transitional face to put sustainable ti
social justice  and promotion of common
good at center of there activities
organizaciones couple of defense is true
and by tekken waves responsibility and his
direction in fact by lord march
di word nord cultivated protective mica
not contegno squeezes con like a nord
must be considered as part of a large  the
group does charles david must carry out
in integrated ue in order to find  alla
sting solutions crudi problems economic
systems and sisters via facebook de moro
learn and practice on the ring many
things the way virus
dave consumptions of exploitation of the
poor indifferenti in which themes and
think about integrates the ecologist just a
new conception of the relationship
between  us n the briefs his new economy
I look at the production of his death in the
well being human being en place new
tricks for love interpersonal novice
horse politics all of you to boarding
proposed days laudato be on
emanuensi gems brothers all
[Music]
mustapha skype she has  took days today
tomorrow things fiction is built to day
is built too if not been
isolation in community and in armani
[Music]